the indispensable nation is just a happy
mythology we like to tell ourselves to
justify policies that we happen to
already do many times for other reasons
[Music]
hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV today
we're talking with Trevor thrall he is a
senior fellow who covers defense and
security issues at the Cato Institute
he's also a professor at George Mason
University Trevor thanks for talking to
me hey great to be here you have written
a fair amount about the kind of Trump
doctrine obviously this is a you know
it's it's a constantly be re re revised
it's like a Google Doc that probably has
50 different people but you know
monkeying with it how do you see like
how can we meaningfully talk about
Donald Trump's foreign policy and what
it's likely to go towards yeah great
great question I think it's he's so
inconsistent it is a little tricky
putting your finger right on it but I
think we now know enough that we can
identify at least three big pillars to
start talking about it
the first is invited in that America
first tagline and that is a sort of uber
American nationalism and what I think
that really means at heart is that Trump
is indifferent to really the the project
of the post-world War two american
foreign policy regime which was the OU
building and maintaining a liberal
international order he doesn't care
about the whole international order he
cares only about America's NATO other
allies the providing global public goods
like you know safe passage in the ocean
he doesn't think or care much about a
those things so that's number one number
two is on the other hand you might think
that made him sort of a dove or
something but I think the second thing
is that he's actually sort of hawkish
he's actually very I don't think he
wants to intervene very often doesn't
care too much about the rest world but
when he does I think he wants to bring
the hammer and so if you'd listened to
his words about Isis I'm addict aiding
radical Islam and stuff like that so I
think he's you know he's not interesting
the general project of liberal
internationalism but when it comes to
push and shove I think he kind of has a
zero-sum way of thinking about the world
we're gonna win and we're gonna beat
people up hard to do it and I think the
third piece that we've seen very clearly
and also kind of stems from the America
first tagline is his economic
nationalism which is again very a big
break from the Republican Party for sure
but even from democratic notes
so you know trade with China is on the
horizon that sort of stuff tariffs and
and you know no support really I can see
for free trade how problematic I think a
lot of people is certainly in the
Republican establishment and the
Democratic establishment I mean they are
freaking out every time that Trump or
you know whether it's a mad asur
somebody else says today doe hey you
guys you better pony up otherwise we
might just go away would that be
catastrophic
not necessarily for America but for the
world but because one of the arguments
is you destabilize the liberal
international order you get more chaos
and then America is going to be called
in anyway having said that if we don't
change things we're stuck with the
status quo where we're spending the you
have a bazillion dollars a year on
defense much more than other countries
you know so how do you know what do you
thing for the maintenance of the liberal
international order is that the United
States gets the most from maintaining
this order and so it's okay that we
could pay the most so in other words
we're getting our money for our you know
value for our money
but Trump clearly does not believe that
and so his call to reassess to put it
gently NATO and other arrangements with
allies around the world is really
freaking people out because I think many
people do believe that the u.s. is the
indispensable nation if we aren't
putting our hands over everything
everywhere the trouble will burst out
all over the place is there I mean a lot
of people believe that should is that
true I think that is an illusion there
may be special cases where that's true
but in fact I think the indispensable
nation is just a happy mythology we like
to tell ourselves to justify policies
that we happen to already do many times
for other reasons so if we loosen up our
standing on the the sea lanes and in the
Chinese seas and stuff like that it
doesn't mean Australia is suddenly going
to become under the boot of China I see
no reason why that would happen I mean
remember China is the country that's the
biggest winner from the current liberal
international order are there a few
things they might tweak I suppose but
not the big pillars of non-intervention
and sovereignty and stuff like that what
is your sense of you know the other
more specific issue is Trump's bromance
with Russia or with Putin should we be
worried about Putin being an
expansionist or is he actually a
nationalist you know because I've even
had conversations with people who kind
of some time during the conversation
they stopped saying Russia and they stop
saying the Soviets and I mean you know
and that's understandable because that's
the world that we were raised in and
it's the world that dominated our
thinking for 70 years but you know is is
Putin so dangerous that we absolutely
have to always be at a kind of cold war
with Russia yeah that's a very good
question I guess I'm I would say you
know maybe I think there's good reason
for people in his neighborhood to be
worried about for sure I mean just ask
Ukraine the Baltics obviously have
reason as they always have to be near
such a powerful neighbor anyone who is
not doesn't have good relationships with
the the most powerful neighbors is got
to be worried but I don't see that being
a threat to the United States on the
other hand whether Russia owns part of
Ukraine or does not does not affect our
national security
Russia's GNP is you know a little is a
little bigger than Mexico's right now
they are not a superpower
so then how should the United States are
assuming that you would like to tweak
elements of the American projection of
power around the globe what what it what
are the principles that should guide it
and these might be different than
Trump's but what do we do to you know if
not go full Ron Paul or George McGovern
and bring the troops home how do we
start making better allocation decisions
on how much we're sending around and to
how many places I think you know it's
funny it depends on which side of Trump
you listen to but I think you know maybe
like a broken clock that's right a
couple times a day
Trump has said things that to me make a
lot of sense I think pulling back troops
from the Middle East
we spent five sure if we stopped the war
today we'd have spent five trillion
dollars in the last 15 years in the war
on terror but look what we have to show
for it we have we have worse conditions
than before 9/11 to show for it clearly
we can start by doing no harm and
pulling back from active intervention
around the world playing whack-a-mole
with terraces is a terrible idea then I
think it is
time to reassess alliances allies are
people who help mutually ensure each
other safety we don't have allies we
have clients Europe is so rich and it's
very easy for them to pay for their own
defence they don't want to because
they're rational people they've got
someone else to pay for it I think we
should reassess what we do with NATO we
don't need to be part of NATO we can be
a partner to NATO we don't have to
promise to be there and spend money to
secure Europe that seems to me to make
very little sense so Trump has frankly
said a bunch of things that makes I'm
not sure he got there the same way that
I do in my mind but he said some things
that make perfect sense we can't pull
back quite a bit who you know would say
in the you know over since World War two
what you know what administration do you
think put together the best it by year
lights the best national security team
or kind of defense operations to you
know that got the job done well without
overstepping either America's financial
or ethical boundaries and things like
that like who who should we be modeling
ourselves on it's a great question ah I
guess my my favorite team is George Bush
senior's it was this was like Brent
Scowcroft
George Schultz yep exactly right and and
and Bush himself they were they were
realists they were very prudent they
didn't think the United States should
engage in a lot of foreign intervention
or nation-building I think they were
they did although they did things were
yeah yeah that was I mean it was
interesting because I I don't think it
was justified but then they also limited
this the scale and that's right
instincts that having made sort of one
you know mistake in a sense where I
think they let themselves be influenced
too heavily by sort of the existing
Carter doctrine and they'll save the oil
kind of thing I think that they then
showed more prudence than anyone since
has shown in limiting the the US
military effort there and and also in
making sure that they weren't doing this
unilaterally I think that's sort of
underappreciated over the last 15 years
I think the US has gotten ahead of the
rest of the world and that just begs for
more problems a lot of libertarian for
policy people are in international
relations people are some variety of
realist as you are talk a little bit
about what that means and how how we can
sell it better because it's I think it's
a very attractive kind of sensibility
for many people but it oftentimes it's
hard to it doesn't hold hold up to you
know crying children or you know dead
people on a beach right yeah I guess the
realist position really has a couple of
basic you know principles that guide it
and the first is the simple
understanding that the world is anarchic
and every nation is responsible for its
own security
there is no 911 to call when your
country's invaded so the this leads to a
basic problem in world politics which is
every country is kind of out for itself
and things that each country does for
its own security tends to make other
countries nervous because if I buy a
bunch of tanks for my own defense other
people could reasonably assume these
were for me to attack them with and so
that that's really kind of the driving
engine and then what causes war
typically from a realist standpoint or
trouble is when you have imbalances of
power or quickly changing balances of
power and where countries get really
nervous well if the country nearby is
getting powerful very quickly I might
have to attack them now to avoid getting
beaten up later and so the problem with
this from a public standpoint is it
sounds cold
it sounds calculating it you treat
States like billiard balls on a pool
table thus colliding instead of the
human story underneath people are dying
and fighting and so on and so forth and
I think to sell this foreign policy
better requires you know connecting the
calculation to the emotion so when you
ask someone why shouldn't we go help
Syria this is a tragedy these are people
are dying don't you see and you say yes
I see that but what you're asking is for
Americans to go die instead and why is
that fair and so it's a difficult
conversation no matter how you do it but
I think that might help people
understand why it's important to be
restrained well we'll leave it there we
have been talking with the Cato
Institute's Trevor thrall he's also a
professor at George Mason universe
Trevor thanks turtle thanks doc
appreciate it for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie
[Music]